boomer sooner boomers ooh thanks that's
a great way to start home it's like in
my nightmares did it I heard that song
more than I heard my own song when we
played Texas and Oklahoma is it just do
you just size each other up when you're
around each other not once I think we've
made it in and we've made it to the NFL
and I think we're both pretty confident
we're still the better school no doubt
has been so so we're over asked what
here's a job we are pretty horrible
right now you are the class of the big
12 I'll say this this is what I got over
him in Oklahoma I'm have more pictures
in the Oklahoma Hall of Fame than he
does
you getting sacked me getting sexiest
pictures up there Roy Williams that's
the plan that's the play that's the play
of the Red River robbery I mean everyone
seen that play I mean that is not the
biggest picture you know and Texas fans
think I should have blocked them and
threw the ball that's that's what
they're down in history forever their
play will never stop you're right for a
while I want to talk about running backs
yeah there's this other thing going on
the NFL right now with levy on bail and
it's I'm seeing them on jet skis and we
are we are two people that go we've
always wanted someone that's under the
franchise tag to sit out ten weeks yeah
to save this movie coming out yeah it
might be happening right now you were a
guy that got an insane amount of touches
you had one season where you were the
sixth most of all time teams run running
backs into the ground can you give the
perspectives of someone that had 449
touches in a season yeah to fans that
maybe don't get I don't like they hate
when people say run them into the ground
man they didn't run me into the ground I
mean that's I'm running back and I was
yeah having a great year and then all
offense we were you know we're balling
we had it we had a great great system
going and they didn't run me to the
ground by any means I felt great after I
had no sir I had a broken hand which on
a mini game and ya know off-season now
I'm surgery anything like that but no me
uh it's a business you know so I think
they're doing what they're they want to
do he's doing what he's want to do but I
think you take a look at Emma Smith when
he was holding out they were only two or
three to start yeah Charles Haley came
naked injuries office you know for going
naked and okay this guy so a fun lady
I'll bail tomorrow murder yeah I would
do it I wouldn't do it but I'm him yes I
would probably you know do what he's
doing
hold it out ten weeks come back for six
game ball out and then your body hey I
appreciate what you got done done for me
alright so hear me out on this this is
something that we've talked about for a
while and I do think it needs to be
changed in the NFL recap well the salary
cap or finding a way to do right by
running backs running backs I know you
don't like the phrase getting run into
the ground and all that but I always say
it's the most physically demanding
position and alright words I mean you
know I'll run through take on Fletcher
Cox you know sit there block Ray Lewis
standing still when he blitzes I just
think it's unfair that let's just say
guys like Arian Foster Alfred Morris who
were not drafted or late in round ranks
and there they are top five in the NFL
in rushing and they never really fairly
get compensated right I have a thing
where I would like to see the NFL almost
like the NBA go you know we're gonna
make a special cap exemption for these
running backs who might be top five in
the NFL in rushing and you get paid
almost a franchise tag money that it
doesn't even count against a salary yeah
the player performance was right so I I
guess what I'm saying is do you like my
idea I love your idea and I think it's
correct mean the running back is the
most physically demanding position and
then the film yes you're getting hit
yeah I'm gonna block yeah I'm gonna
catch so especially a guy like Lady I'm
bill and myself were we were do like and
we're running and we're catching yeah
you know so I think you know that's a
great point you made and and just in
general you know the whole NFL not just
a running back but more so than running
back because it is the most physically
demanding position and you take a lot of
hits right yeah beat up it just it makes
me think right now that I'm looking at
levy on bail and I'm looking at the
public and the public has started to get
angry it goes back to fantasy fantasy
where where's my levy on bail Steelers
fans are going we're all we don't have a
win right now we're starting off slow
but no one's thinking about levia right
and I feel like some teammates call them
out of those horseshit yeah
don't do that I mean you never talk
about another guy situation or his
contract obviously one in there but I
think you know I think we buy the team
to make those comments right but I give
lady our kudos for standing up for
himself and trying to reset the running
back marking and trying to be like hey
we're important you know we're just as
important as a quarterback so that's
that's huge for you running back Steve
would you guys talk to each other about
that when you're playing do you guys
look at it and go one of us has to kind
of hold out to reset this market no you
know what just I think it's all about
the play but when you are negotiating
you think about trying to reel it when I
was negotiating you know for my my deal
that's what I was I was like you know
what the last two three years hasn't
been running by taking the first round
I'm trying to reset the market and I
sort of you know got it jump-started a
little bit but it still isn't where it
needs to be think about this sake one
Barclay because he was taken second
overall is a top five paid running back
in the NFL there's no other position
where a quarterback or like any position
gets drafted that high and they're
already top five that's how low the
running back market is it's very low
yeah which is crazy running back you
talk about a physical you got okay five
years of killing yourself then they of
course want to lowball you on your
contracts and go oh well you might be
too worn out did you feel like teams
tried to use that against you when you
were negotiating contracts going man
he's had a lot of wear and tear already
um just trying to remember there wasn't
a lot of teens because like I said I
took care of myself I had a broken ankle
my rookie year right but prior to that I
had a hand and that was it I just have a
random question what is what does Jerry
Jones like to party with just because
like I'd love for him to look at me and
be like am you enjoy that drew and I
don't know it's great there's a good guy
you know Jerry Jerry he gets a bad rep
you know obviously he's too involved
with the Cowboys and the hell is this
team you know if it was my team I would
you know you know go in and do whatever
I wanted to but he's the complete
opposite of what the perception feels
he's a guy that he's obviously doesn't
come around practice like he lets the
coaches do their deal he's in the locker
room to congratulate but after a loss
you know
he's like right there to comfort you
he's right there to comfort you even
though you played shitty he'll be like
you know hey guys I know how much work
you put in I know how how things are
going I know how hard you guys work
just get it together figured out coaches
same way he's a lot harder on the
coaches because you know obviously
that's everyone is but he's great the
party without you know we've had some
good time Johnny Walker blues but I've
had some Johnnie Walker he actually
turned me on to the to the Johnnie
Walker Blue so yeah well that's me Ford
it it's really how we let him pay for it